Bonjour à tous. Premièrement, j'aimerais dire que c'était simplement fantastique
d'être parmi vous ces derniers jours.
Deuxièmement, c'est un grand honneur que de pouvoir un peu inspirer
cet extraordinaire rassemblement de personnes
d'avoir eu ces discussions passionnantes.
Je pense être globalement en accord
avec les choses que j'ai pu entendre.
J'arrive directement
de la profonde forêt tropicale en Equateur,
où j'étais en expédition -- vous n'y avez accès que par avion --
avec un peuple indigène avec des peintures sur le visage
et des plumes de perroquets sur leurs couvre-chefs.
Cette tribu se bat actuellement pour garder les compagnies pétrolières,
et les réseaux routiers, hors de leurs forêts.
Ils luttent pour développer leur propre manière de vivre au sein de la forêt
dans un monde qui est propre, un monde qui n'est pas contaminé,
un monde qui n'est pas pollué.
Ce qui a été tellement stupéfiant pour moi, et qui coïncidait avec
ce que nous discutions ici à TED,
c'est que là-bas, en plein milieu de la forêt tropicale,
étaient installés des panneaux solaires -- les premiers dans cette région de l'Equateur --
qui avaient pour but principal de pomper de l'eau potable
pour que les femmes n'aient plus à descendre dans des puits pour le faire.
L'eau était propre et parce qu'ils avaient beaucoup de batteries,
ils étaient capables de stocker beaucoup d'électricité.
Donc chaque maison -- et je pense qu'il y en avait huit --
dans cette petite communauté -- pouvait avoir de la lumière
pendant à peu près une demi-heure chaque soir.
Et il y avait ce Chef, vêtu de sa parure souveraine, avec un ordinateur portable.
(Rires)
Cet homme, a déjà vu le monde extérieur mais est revenu,
et il disait "Vous savez, nous sommes soudainement entré dans
une nouvelle ère alors que nous ne connaissions pas l'existence de l'homme blanc
il y a 50 ans. Nous nous retrouvons maintenant avec des ordinateurs portables,
et il y a certaines choses que nous souhaitons apprendre du monde moderne.
Nous voulons nous informer à propos de sujets comme la santé.
Nous souhaitons savoir ce que font les autres hommes -- cela nous intéresse.
Nous désirons également apprendre de nouvelles langues.
Nous voulons apprendre l'anglais, le français et peut-être le chinois,
nous sommes bons en langues."
Donc il y avait cet homme avec son petit ordinateur portable
se battant contre les différentes formes de pression --
notamment celle de la dette, la dette extérieure de l'Equateur --
luttant contre la pression de la Banque Mondiale, du FMI et bien-sûr
celle des personnes qui veulent exploiter leur forêt et extraire du pétrole.
De là-bas, je suis directement venu ici.
Bien-sûr, mon véritable champ d'expertise
concerne un tout autre type de civilisation --
Je n'utiliserai pas le mot "civilisation"
mais une façon de vivre, une manière d'être différente.
Nous avons parlé plus tôt -- avec ce magnifique speech de Wade Davis
des différentes cultures des êtres humains à travers le globe --
mais le monde n'est pas seulement composé d'être humains,
il y a également les animaux.
Je vous propose de vous apporter dans cette conférence TED,
ce que j'apporte partout dans le monde, la voix du royaume animal.
Trop souvent, nous ne voyions que quelques slides ou un bout de film,
mais ces êtres ont des voix qui expriment des choses.
Par exemple, je vais vous saluer
comme le ferait un chimpanzé des forêts de Tanzanie.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh!
(Applaudissements)
J'étudie les chimpanzés de Tanzanie depuis 1960.
Pendant ce temps, de nouvelles technologies
ont peu à peu transformé la façon
dont travaillaient les biologistes sur le terrain.
Par exemple, pour la première fois, il y a quelques années,
en collectant simplement quelques échantillons d'excréments
nous étions capable de les analyser et de réaliser un profilage ADN.
Donc pour la première fois, nous étions capable de savoir quels chimpanzés mâles
étaient les pères de chaque enfant.
Etant donné que les chimpanzés ont une société aux mœurs très légères.
Cela a par conséquent ouvert une grande voie à la recherche.
Nous utilisons également le GSI -- Geographic ... enfin peu importe, GSI --
afin de déterminer les catégories de chimpanzés.
Nous utilisons aussi ... -- vous pouvez voir que je ne suis pas trop fan de cela --
nous utilisons l'imagerie satellite
pour voir le niveau de déforestation de la zone.
Il y a également des équipements infrarouges
qui permettent de voir les animaux la nuit
et le matériel pour enregistrer des vidéos
et de l'audio devient de meilleure qualité.
De multiples façons, nous pouvons aujourd'hui faire des choses
que nous ne pouvions pas réaliser quand j'ai commencé en 1960.
C'est notamment le cas quand des chimpanzés ou d'autres animaux
avec des cerveaux importants sont étudiés en captivité.
La technologie moderne nous aide à identifier
des niveaux de cognition avancés chez ces animaux.
Aujourd'hui, nous savons qu'ils sont capables de performances
que étaient scientifiquement impensables
quand j'ai commencé ma carrière.
Je pense que le chimpanzé en captivité qui est le plus
intellectuellement performant est une femelle qui s'appelle "Ai" et qui se trouve au Japon.
Son nom signifie "Amour"
et elle travaille avec un partenaire avec une écoute extraordinaire.
Elle aime son ordinateur.
Elle abandonnerait son grand groupe, son eau courante
ses arbres et tout ce qu'elle a
pour venir s'asseoir devant cet ordinateur.
C'est comme un jeu vidéo pour elle, elle est complètement accro.
Cependant, elle a 28 ans et fait des choses avec son écran
et son clavier plus rapidement que la plupart des humains.
Elle réalise des tâches très complexes mais je n'ai pas le temps d'en parler.
La chose la plus étonnante avec cette femelle,
c'est qu'elle n'aime pas faire d'erreurs.
Si elle fait une mauvaise performance et que son score n'est pas bon,
elle va grimper et taper sur la vitre
-- parce qu'elle ne peut voir le scientifique --
pour demander de refaire l'exercice.
Elle s'est déjà bien concentrée
pendant 20 minutes environ qu'elle redemande à recommencer depuis le début,
juste pour la satisfaction de le faire mieux.
La nourriture n'est pas importante -- elle a une récompense minime
comme un raisin pour une réponse correcte --
et elle ferait cela sans aucune contrepartie, si on le lui demandait.
Nous avons donc aujourd'hui un chimpanzé qui utilise un ordinateur.
Les chimpanzés, gorilles, orang-outans apprennent aussi le langage gestuel de l'Homme.
Cela me rappelle la première fois que j'étais à Gombe en 1960.
Je m'en souviens comme si c'était hier.
La première fois que je pénétrais la végétation,
les chimpanzés me fuyaient pour la plupart,
même si certains se sont un peu habitués.
J'aperçus cette masse sombre, juché au-dessus d'un nid à termites
et j'observais attentivement avec mes lunettes.
C'était un adulte mâle que j'ai surnommé David Barbe-Grise.
Au passage, la science de l'époque ne me recommandait pas de nommer les chimpanzés.
Ils devaient avoir des numéros, c'était plus scientifique.
Passons, David Barbe-Grise et je l'ai vu de mes yeux
arrachait des herbes et les utilisait
pour pêcher des termites dans leur nid souterrain.
Et en plus de cela, il utilisait parfois une brindille à feuilles
et en enlevait les feuilles.
Modifier un objet pour le rendre utile a un but spécifique,
le début de la fabrication d'outils.
La raison pour laquelle j'étais tellement excitée par cette découverte,
était qu'à l'époque, l'on pensait que les humains
et les humains seuls, utilisaient et fabriquaient des outils.
Quand j'étais à l'école, nous étions définis comme l'Homme, le fabricant d'outils.
Alors quand Louis Leakey, mon mentor, apprit la nouvelle
il dit "Ah et bien nous devons à présent redéfinir l'Homme, redéfinir l'outil
ou accepter les chimpanzés comme humains."
(Rires)
Nous savons que rien qu'à Gombe, il y a chez les chimpanzés 9 différentes façons
d'utiliser des objets pour des objectifs différents.
De plus, dans d'autres parties de l'Afrique,
où des chimpanzés ont été étudiés,
il y a des façons d'utiliser des outils complètement différentes.
Il semble que ces connaissances sont transmises
de génération en génération via l'observation,
l'imitation et la pratique -- la définition de la culture humaine.
Ce que nous avons trouvé, c'est qu'après ces 40 ans
passés à étudier les chimpanzés
et les autres grands singes, comme j'aime le dire, d'autres mammifères
avec des cerveaux complexes et des systèmes sociaux,
nous avons découvert qu'il n'y avait pas de frontière précise
qui sépare les humains du reste du royaume animal.
C'est une frontière très floue
et qui le devient de plus en plus quand nous voyons des animaux faire des choses
que nous pensions, de manière arrogante, être une exclusivité de l'Homme.
Les chimpanzés -- il n'y a pas assez de temps pour parler de leurs vies fascinantes --
ils ont cette longue enfance, 5 ans
à être allaités et à dormir avec leur mère,
et ensuite 3,4 à 5 ans
de dépendance émotionnelle envers la mère même quand un nouveau bébé naît.
Apprendre est crucial à cette période, quand le comportement est flexible,
et il y a des tonnes de choses à apprendre dans la société chimpanzé.
Les liens affectifs très forts
développés durant cette enfance avec la mère,
les frères et les soeurs,
peuvent durer une vie entière,
une vie qui peut atteindre les 60 années.
Ils peuvent en fait vivre plus de 60 ans en captivité
alors que nous étions à 40 ans dans la jungle.
Nous avons découvert que les chimpanzés pouvaient exprimer de la compassion et de l'altruisme.
Dans leur communication non verbale, qui est très riche,
ils utilisent beaucoup de sons adaptés à chaque contexte.
Mais ils peuvent aussi se servir du toucher, de postures et de la gestuelle.
Et que font-ils ?
Ils s'embrassent, s'étreignent, se tiennent la main.
Ils se tapotent le dos, ils fanfaronnent, secouent leurs poings.
Le genre de choses que nous faisons
et ils font de même dans un contexte similaire.
Ils possèdent une coopération sophistiquée.
Parfois ils chassent, c'est plutôt rare
mais quand ils le font, ils montrent une véritable coopération réfléchie
et ils partagent la proie.
Nous avons vu qu'ils exprimaient des émotions assez similaires --parfois même, les mêmes--
que celles que nous décrivons comme la joie, la tristesse, la peur, le désespoir.
Ils connaissent la souffrance physique et psychique.
Et ... je n'ai pas le temps de vous détailler
quelques exemples probants.
Mais il y a des étudiants talentueux, dans les meilleures universités
qui étudient les émotions des animaux ainsi que leurs personnalités.
Nous savons que les chimpanzés comme d'autres créatures
peuvent se reconnaître dans un miroir -- seul et parmi d'autres animaux.
Ils ont un sens de l'humour et ce genre de choses
qui étaient pensés comme des prérogatives humaines.
Ceci nous enseigne un nouveau respect et c'est un nouveau respect
pas seulement pour les chimpanzés
mais aussi pour les autres fascinants animaux avec lesquels nous partageons cette planète.
Une fois que nous serons capable d'admettre
que nous ne sommes pas les seuls êtres dotés de personnalités et esprits
et par-dessus tout de sentiments, nous commencerons
à penser à la manière dont nous utilisons et abusons
tant de créatures sensibles sur cette planète.
Nous comprendrions que nous devrions avoir honte, à mon avis.
La triste nouvelle, c'est que ces chimpanzés
qui auront, plus que toute autre créature, réussi à nous enseigner un peu d'humilité
sont en train de disparaître rapidement de la nature.
Ils disparaissent pour différentes raisons
que vous tous dans la salle ne connaissez que trop bien.
La déforestation, la croissance démographique qui demande plus d'espace.
Ils disparaissent à cause d'entreprises forestières
qui coupent de manière disproportionnée.
Ils sont en train de disparaître en plein cœur des montagnes africaines
à cause des multinationales de l'abattage qui viennent et font des routes
-- où comme en Equateur
et d'autres zones où les forêts n'ont pas encore été touchées --
pour extraire du pétrole ou du bois.
Ce mouvement aussi amené dans le Bassin du Congo et d'autres régions du monde
ce que nous appelons le marché de la chasse commerciale, le Bush-Meat.
Cela veut dire qu'après des centaines, peut-être même des milliers d'années,
où les hommes ont vécu dans ces forêts ou partout ailleurs,
en harmonie avec leur monde, tuant les animaux dont ils avaient besoin
pour eux-mêmes et leurs familles,
désormais, à cause de la construction des routes
les chasseurs peuvent venir des villes,
tirer sur tout ce qui bouge
tout ce qui est plus gros qu'un rat, le consommer, le sécher ou le fumer.
A présent, ils transportent tout cela dans des camions de transport des arbres
ou dans des camions miniers vers les villes pour le revendre.
Les gens vont payer plus pour cette nourriture sauvage
que pour de la nourriture ordinaire, c'est culturellement meilleur.
Ce n'est pas durable et les grands sites d'abattage dans les forêts
demandent maintenant de la viande. C'est pourquoi les pygmées du Bassin du Congo,
qui vivaient avec respect et harmonie
pendant des centaines d'années sont maintenant corrompus.
On leur donne des armes, ils chassent pour les entreprises, ils reçoivent de l'argent.
Leur culture est en train d'être détruite
en même temps que les animaux dont ils dépendent.
Au final, quand les sites d'abattage ferment, il ne reste plus rien.
Nous avons déjà parlé de la destruction de la diversité culturelle humaine
et bien je l'ai vu de mes propres yeux.
Cette image effroyable de l'Afrique -- et j'aime l'Afrique,
que voyons-nous en Afrique ?
Nous voyons de la déforestation,
nous voyons le désert qui s'étend, nous voyons de la famine massive
nous voyons la maladie ainsi que des populations se développant dans des zones
où les capacités de la terre
sont tout simplement insuffisantes pour leur survie.
Ils sont trop pauvres pour s'acheter de la nourriture.
Est-ce que ces gens dont on parlait jadis,
sur l'Ile de Pâques, qui ont coupé leur dernier arbre -- étaient-ils stupides ?
Savaient-ils ce qui était en train de se passer ?
Bien sûr que oui. Mais quand on connait la pauvreté alarmante
dans ces régions du monde.
la question n'est pas de savoir s'il faut laisser cet arbre pour demain mais
"Comment vais-je nourrir ma famille aujourd'hui ?
Je vais peut-être récupérer quelques dollars de plus avec ce dernier arbre
qui nous permettra de tenir un peu plus longtemps
et puis nous prierons pour que quelque chose
nous sauve de notre fin inévitable".
C'est une image bien sinistre.
La chose que nous possédons et qui nous différencie principalement
des chimpanzés et des autres créatures,
c'est notre langage complexe.
Un langage qui nous permet de parler à nos enfants
de choses qui ne sont pas là. De notions théoriques.
Nous pouvons parler du passé, imaginer le futur,
débattre sur des sujets avec les autres
pour que les idées s'améliorent avec la connaissance du groupe.
Nous pouvons le faire en discutant,
avec une vidéo ou par écrit.
Et nous gâchons cette faculté incroyable
en détruisant le monde.
Dans les pays développés, c'est même pire,
car nous avons toute l'information nous permettant de comprendre
la stupidité de nos actes.
Savez-vous que nous accueillons nos nouveaux-nés
dans un monde, dans des endroits où l'eau les empoisonnent?
Où l'air et la nourriture
de la terre contaminée les empoisonnent.
Cela ne concerne pas uniquement le Tiers-Monde, c'est partout.
Savez-vous que nous possédons tous 50 produits chimiques
qui n'existaient pas dans nos corps il y a 50 ans ?
Et que bien des maladies comme l'asthme
et certains types de cancers se développent rapidement
autour des zones où nos déchets toxiques sont ensevelis?
Nous sommes en train de nous nuire à travers le monde
nuire aux animaux tout comme la nature.
Mère Nature qui nous a donné la vie.
Mère Nature, où je pense que nous devons passer plus de temps
partout où il y a des arbres, des fleurs et des oiseaux
pour notre bon développement psychologique.
Cependant, des centaines et des centaines d'enfants
dans les pays développés n'ont jamais vu la nature,
parce qu'ils grandissent dans le béton.
Tout ce qu'ils connaissent c'est une réalité virtuelle
avec l'impossibilité de partir et s'étendre au soleil,
ou dans un forêt sous de multitudes tâches de lumière
créées par la canopée.
Comme vous le savez, je parcoure le monde
J'ai dû quitter la forêt, là où j'aime être.
J'ai dû quitter ces fascinants chimpanzés
étudiés par mes étudiants et l'équipe sur place
car, découvrant que leur nombre étant passé de 2 millions
il y a 100 ans à 150 000 maintenant,
j'ai compris que je devais quitter la forêt et faire ce que je pouvais
pour en faire prendre conscience à travers la planète.
Et plus je parle de la situation désespérée des chimpanzés,
plus je réalise à quel point tout est interconnecté.
Les problèmes du Tiers Monde
proviennent trop souvent de l'avidité du monde développé
et cela s'assemble parfaitement, pour donner -- non pas du sens,
car il y a de l'espoir dans le sens, dites-vous -- mais donner du non-sens.
"Comment pouvons-nous le faire?"
a demandé quelqu'un hier.
En parcourant le monde, je n'ai cessé de rencontrer de jeunes personnes qui avaient perdu espoir.
Ils étaient désespérés.
Ils pensaient "Bien, ce que nous faisons ne changera rien,
bois, mange et sois gai car nous mourrons demain."
"Tout est sans espoir" disent les médias.
J'ai également rencontré des personnes en colère
mais la colère peut se transformer en violence
et nous savons tous où cela peut mener.
J'ai 3 petits-enfants.
Quand des étudiants me disent
au lycée ou à l'université "Nous sommes en colère."
ou "Nous sommes remplis de désespoir car nous pensons
que vous avez compromis notre futur et qu'il n'y a plus rien à faire."
et que je regarde dans les yeux de mon petit-fils
et repense à tout ce que nous avons fait à la Terre
Je ressens cette profonde honte. C'est pourquoi en 1991, en Tanzanie,
J'ai lancé un programme appelé "Roots and Shoots".
Il y a quelques brochures disponibles à l'extérieur,
et si certains parmi s'occupent d'enfants ou souhaitent agir pour leur futur
je vous supplie de prendre cette brochure.
"Roots and Shoots" est un programme pour l'espoir.
Les racines permettent une fondation solide.
Les pousses semblent minuscules
mais pour avoir de la lumière, elles peuvent détruire des murs de briques.
Imaginez le mur de briques comme la somme de nos problèmes
que nous avons infligés à cette planète.
Voila notre message d'espoir.
Des centaines, des milliers de jeunes à travers la planète
peuvent réussir et créer un meilleur monde.
Le message le plus important de "Roots and Shoots"
c'est que chaque personne peut faire la différence.
Chaque individu a un rôle à jouer.
Nous agissons tous sur le monde chaque jour,
et vous les scientifiques le savez
que même si vous restez dans votre lit toute la journée, vous respirez
de l'oxygène et rejetez du C02 et allez aux toilettes,
et plein d'autres choses.
Vous êtes en train d'agir sur cette planète.
Donc le programme "Roots and Shoots"
implique les jeunes dans 3 types de projets.
Des projets qui permettent d'améliorer leur environnement.
Premièrement, des projets pour s'occuper des questions de la communauté humaine.
Deuxièmement des projets pour les animaux même domestiques, et je dois dire
que j'ai tout appris des comportements animaux
bien avant d'être à Gombe avec les chimpanzés mais avec mon chien, Rusty
qui était mon compagnon d'enfance.
Dernièrement, nous avons des projets pour l'environnement local.
L'attribution des projets dépendra de l'âge des enfants
nous allons aujourd'hui de la maternelle à l'université.
S'ils vivent dans les villes ou en milieu rural.
S'ils vivent dans des familles aisés ou modestes.
Cela dépendra dans quel partie, disons, d'Amérique ils vivent.
Nous sommes présents dans tous les pays car les problèmes en Floride
sont différents des problèmes à New-York.
Cela va dépendre du pays d'habitation
et nous sommes déjà dans plus de 60 pays avec environ 5000 groupes actifs
et j'ai des nouvelles d'une multitude de groupes
qui n'existaient pas avant car les enfants portent le programme
et le diffusent eux-mêmes.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'ils se prennent au jeu,
et se sont les seuls à décider de ce qu'ils font.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose que leurs parents leur ont dit de faire,
ou que leurs professeurs leurs ont enseigné.
C'est efficace parce qu'ils décident d'agir par eux-mêmes :
"Nous voulons nettoyer cette rivière
et réintroduire les poissons qui étaient là."
"Nous souhaitons enlever les déchets toxiques
de cette zone et avoir un jardin biologique."
"Nous voulons passer du temps avec les personnes âgées
pour écouter leurs histoires voire les enregistrer."
"Nous voulons travailler dans un refuge d'animaux."
"Nous souhaitons en apprendre plus sur sur les animaux. Nous voulons..."
etc etc. C'est vraiment très encourageant pour moi.
Comme je voyage 300 jours par an,
partout il y a un groupe de "Roots and Shoots".
Partout il y a des enfants avec des yeux pleins d'étoiles qui disent,
"Regardez ce que nous avons pu faire."
La technologie joue aussi un rôle,
grâce à cette nouvelle façon de communiquer de façon électronique,
ces enfants peuvent communiquer entre eux dans le monde entier.
Si quelqu'un souhaite nous aider, nous avons tellement d'idées
mais avons besoin d'aide. De l'aide pour créer le bon système
qui permettra à ces jeunes personnes de communiquer leur enthousiasme.
Mais également, et c'est important, communiquer leur désespoir,
pour dire "Nous avons essayé cela mais ça ne marche pas, que devons-nous faire?"
et qu'ensuite un autre groupe réponde à ces enfants
qui peuvent être en Amérique ou en Israel
disant "Oui, vous vous êtes un peu trompés. Voici comment vous devriez le faire."
La philosophie est très simple.
Nous ne croyons pas en la violence.
Pas de violence, pas de bombes ni d'armes à feu.
Ce n'est pas la manière de résoudre les problèmes.
La violence mène à la violence, du moins c'est mon avis.
Donc comment résoudre les problèmes ?
Les outils pour résoudre les problèmes sont la connaissance et la compréhension.
Connaissez les faits et comprenez comme ils s'intègrent de façon globale.
Beaucoup de travail et de persévérance, n'abandonnez pas
et de l'amour et de la compassion, qui donnent un respect pour toute vie.
Combien de minutes de plus ? 2, 1 ?
Chris Anderson: 1, 1 à 2.
Jane Goodall: 2, 2, je vais en prendre 2.
(Rires)
Est-ce que vous allez m'expulser ?
Passons, donc "Roots and Shoots"
est en train de changer la vie de jeunes personnes.
C'est ce à quoi je dévoue la plus grande partie de mon énergie.
Je pense qu'un groupe comme celui-ci peut avoir un impact majeur,
pas seulement parce que vous pouvez partagez de la technologie avec nous,
mais parce que beaucoup d'entre vous ont des enfants.
Et si vous parlez de ce programme et le donnez à vos enfants,
ils auront une belle opportunité de sortir et de faire le bien
parce qu'ils ont des parents comme vous.
Il est clair pour moi que vous essayez tous
de rendre le monde meilleur.
C'est très encourageant.
Mais les enfants me demandent...
et cela ne durera pas plus de 2 minutes, je promets
les enfants disent "Dr Jane, est-ce que vous avez de l'espoir pour notre avenir ?
vous voyagez, vous voyez toutes ces choses horribles qui se passent."
Premièrement, le cerveau humain. Je n'ai pas besoin d'en dire plus.
Maintenant que nous savons quels sont les problèmes dans le monde,
les cerveaux humains comme les vôtres s'activent pour résoudre ces problèmes.
Et nous en avons parlé longuement.
Deuxièmement, la résilience de la nature.
Nous pouvons détruire une rivière,
et la ramener à la vie.
Nous pouvons voir une zone entière ravagée
et la faire fleurir comme avant, avec du temps et un peu d'aide.
Et troisièmement, le dernier ou avant-dernier orateur a parlé
de l'indomptable esprit humain.
Nous sommes ici entourés par les personnes les plus fascinantes
qui font des choses qui semblaient impossibles.
Nelson Mandela, j'ai pris un petit bout de calcaire
venant de la Prison de Robben Island où il a souffert pendant 27 ans,
et en est sorti avec si peu d'amertume qu'il a pu mener son peuple
après l'horreur de l'apartheid, sans un bain de sang.
Même après le 11 septembre, et j'étais à New-York
et j'ai ressenti de la peur -- pourtant, il y avait un tel courage chez les hommes
tellement d'amour et de compassion.
Et puis j'ai ensuite traversé le pays et ressenti la peur
la peur qui amenait les gens à penser
qu'ils ne pouvaient plus s'occuper de l'environnement
de peur de ne pas paraitre patriotique
et j'essayais de les encourager,
quand une personne apparut avec une petite citation de Mahatma Gandhi:
"Si vous regardez dans l'histoire de l'Homme,
vous voyez que tous les régimes totalitaires ont été vaincus par le Bien."
Et juste après, une femme m'a apporté cette petite cloche,
et je terminerai avec cette note.
Elle m'a dit "Si vous parlez d'espoir et de paix, faites sonner ceci.
Le métal de cette cloche provient d'un terrain de mines désamorcé
de la période de Pol Pot
L'un des régimes les plus meurtriers de l'histoire de l'Homme
où la population commence à peine à se reconstruire
après que le régime se soit effondré.
Donc oui, il y a de l'Espoir mais où est l'Espoir ?
Est-il dehors avec les politiciens ?
Il est dans nos mains.
Il est dans les miennes et les vôtres.
et celles de nos enfants.
Cela dépend vraiment de nous.
Nous sommes ceux et celles qui peuvent faire la différence.
Si nous vivons en prenant soin de ne laisser
que la plus légère empreinte écologique possible.
Si nous achetons les choses qui sont éthiques
et n'achetons pas celles qui ne le sont pas
nous pouvons changer le monde en une nuit.
Merci.